welcome back ladies and gents today
we're going to talk about brynn hilde in
the darkness which is a sci-fi mystery
drama as for what exactly this anime
series is about well let's dive right
into it the story begins with a boy
named murakami and his female friend
kuroneko one day guroneko insists the
aliens exist and attempts to show one of
them to murakami however while they're
trying to reach that place they slip off
a dam and get seriously injured but
luckily murakami survives the accident
while exiting the hospital the doctors
tell him that guru naco his friend
didn't luck out and that she died
feeling regretful since then murakami
continued looking at the sky in the hope
of becoming a researcher for nasa to
prove the existence of aliens as
atonement for gorongo ten years later
murakami is now a top student in high
school one day his class is introduced
to a new transfer student named naco who
looks exactly like guroneko murakami
acts like an idiot asking her to show
her underarm in front of the class since
goroneko had three small moles making
him look like a complete perv weirdo
who's into armpits this evidently led
him to get him bitch-lapped later on
during swimming class murakami remains
concerned about naco a student almost
drowns but is saved by a mysterious
force murakami goes to the observatory
as the sole member of the astronomy club
suddenly neko comes in to inform
murakami that his death has been
predicted and to avoid it he mustn't
take a bus home later she insists to
stay even at the observatory but he
takes that as a joke as the two come to
know each other murakami becomes
suspicious of her as she doesn't know
the multiplication table and possesses
inhuman strength ignoring neko's warning
murakami leaves for home without getting
on the bus then suddenly a mudslide
occurs and a huge boulder comes crashing
down on him but nako splits it with
strange powers and saves murakami which
now makes you reconsider approaching
girls and asking them to reveal their
armpits now doesn't it moving on a
harness attached to the nape of nako's
neck was revealed indicating that she is
actually a witch
lost in thought neco demands murakami to
keep her witch identity a secret the
next day neko doesn't appear at school
so murakami's homeroom teacher asks him
to give neco a pamphlet
following the address murakami witnesses
several self-defense force vehicles
passing down from the mountain he finds
neko who's living in an abandoned
village that serves as her hideout while
talking neko says she only transferred
to prevent certain deaths she explains
how she and other witches have been
experimented at a top secret lab until
they escape when an accident occurred
she tells monokami to leave and to not
come back ever again while leaving he
notices the pamphlet in his hands and
runs back into the house that neco is
staying in entering he finds a young
girl who neco introduces as kana it's
revealed that she's unable to move or
speak due to being paralyzed though she
can communicate with a small keyboard
ghana's ability is foresight which
allows it to see future deaths she tells
neco that the lab security has captured
a fellow witch who's shown to be
executed back at the lab as murakami
leaves ghana convinces nako to go back
to school then monogamy comes over again
with bread and sweets he asks nako if
she'd come on the school field trip
that's taking place next weekend
after being absent the previous day neko
comes to school covered in bandages
surprising murakami the next day being
concerned about the absence of neco
murakami runs to the village and finds
neko bleeding profusely on the floor he
takes her to the kitchen to take a
certain pill called death suppressants
explaining that the witches will die if
they don't take the pill within 30 to 35
hours as neco bore some water the
kitchen accidentally burns down along
with the remaining pills worried about
their survival murakami decides to
obtain the pills whatever it takes he
managed to memorize the drug's
identification code thanks to his nerd
photographic memory and deduces where
the pills are manufactured looking up
info on where the factory preserves the
pills they request another witch named
gazumi to use her power of computer
hacking to shut down the factory
security system so they can steal the
pills now i don't know about you but at
this point dude can sure set himself up
with a harem of witches by now anyway
back on track the lab traces someone
searching for information on the drugs
knowing that someone's going to steal
the pills they set a trap by ordering an
assassin witch sauri to move in
forecasting nako's death by sauri ghana
begs neco to stay however neko chooses
to go regardless as there are no options
for their future infiltrating the
factory neko confronts sauri while
murakami looks for the pills reading a
letter neko wrote before murakami
realizes that she's decided to sacrifice
herself to save kana he runs to help her
with the forecast changing to where they
both die and when murakami finds them he
discovers that neko has guroneko's
birthmark on her breast proving the fact
that she is goroneko he's about to
approach saori when she slices nako to
death thinking that all hope is lost
murakami remembers samoari's second
ability could change things around
murakami pierces saori through the heart
as she kills him knowing she'll die from
a wound if left untreated she's forced
to use her ability of time manipulation
to go back to the time before murakami
and neko were killed causing samori to
exhaust her magic pulling a sneaky one
on a time which they're not bad sir not
bad at all however as a side effect of
going back in time murakami forgets the
fact that neko is kuroneko now sauri is
bound to a pipe neko and murakami try to
convince her to join them seeing her is
useless the lab triggers the beacon on
her harness to eject causing her entire
body to melt meanwhile a strange
creature moving across the floor revolts
murakami making him stomp on it hurrying
back to the observatory after managing
to get the pills they find kazumi there
with ghana both of who are only barely
sustaining themselves with the witch's
life secure for now neko goes with
murakami and the class to the ocean but
sadly this is no beach episode boys
however there is a hot springs episode
so not all happiness is lost now where
was i all right here we are there nako
breaks into tears as though she wanted
to see the view for many years later
neko gives murakami a communication
device and a container with a fertilized
alien egg which were entrusted to her by
akane a researcher who's responsible for
the escaped witches later we find out
that gazumi transferred to murakami's
class by using her hacking skills like
the time she did for neko meanwhile the
chief professor of the lab is lectured
by the higher-ups of the organization
who stress the danger of having witches
roam freely shortly afterward another
transfer student named cordori arrives
at the observatory and asks to join the
astronomy club as well with the club now
having enough members murakami says they
should start an astronomical observation
the next night he learns from kazumi
that neko loses part of her memory
whenever she uses her magic which
explains the fact why she can't remember
anything from her childhood that night
while going on a hike to the mountains
neko remarks that she understands the
constellations in the sky as kodori is
watching the stars murakami discovers a
harness on her neck and in that moment
kana foresees nako's death again
believing the busty girl to be involved
godori reveals her ability of
teleportation as proof that she doesn't
want to kill them going back to
stargazing they're not excited at first
but as soon as they see the moon and
saturn's rings through the telescopes
things go through a nice change of pace
while going back kanai tells murakami
that the forecast has been changed and
she saw his death near a lake the next
day they're contacted by another witch
shino who asks for help as she's been
chased by an aa plus witch neko goes to
the lake to help her arriving at the
lake the aa switch fires a powerful beam
from her mouth thus killing shino neko
attempts to fight her but murakami
presses a harness hanging up her magic
not wanting her to waste her life
murakami asks neko to distract the witch
as he has a plan he finds kodori tying
herself up to a pole and commands her to
switch with the witch before she blasts
neko and they succeed by pressing the
harness and the witch is left defeated
before evacuating the area they find out
that kodori is missing they managed to
locate her at a cottage seeing her
bleeding from a lack of pills murakami
share the pills and convince her to keep
living as a member of the astronomy club
the club members play and eat outside on
a hot day the next day murakami goes to
meet his uncle a scientist whom murakami
believes has the capability to reproduce
the pills he demonstrates neko's magic
to convince his uncle after telling
everything about the witches his uncle
agrees to analyze the pill's molecular
structure and look for a way to
synthesize them unfortunately though it
may take several years also murakami has
him look at a fertilized alien egg the
next day godori tells moak army about
rumors that the lab was founded hundreds
of years ago after discovering the alien
ruins and about a powerful witch that
could destroy humanity the lead head
chisato reports to the higher ups after
interrogating the aa plus witch their
top priority is to capture number 1107
and retrieve something known as the
grain meanwhile murakami takes kazumi to
find equipment for the observatory's
computer although she acts as if it's a
date he later takes out a communication
device and turns it on only for it to
display an image of a map and a message
in german kazumi translates the message
as kill the witches now only then will
we reveal the truth the device also
needs a password which makes them
anxious that the messengers aren't
allies so murakami decides to go alone
to the place where the map leads to two
individuals wearing black overcoats
appear at the spot where the device were
activated later that night kazumi comes
into murakami's house to narrow down the
map's topography on sunday moroccan army
arrives at the church indicated on the
map only to find it in ruins he asks an
old lady nearby about the church who
then states that it was unsuspectingly
destroyed however there was no news
coverage for it inspecting the church
murakami finds german notes on the walls
suddenly a police squad appears and
seizes murak army without questioning
fortunately nako makes it in time to
destroy their cars and guns while kotori
teleports the mad chief of police the
girls tell murakami not to be so hard on
himself and they should combine their
strengths together
meanwhile the lab receives reports about
number 1107
number 7620 and a high school boy
murakami who's aiding them gisanto's
assistant goes to find their location
with the help of the witch nanami nanami
demonstrates her ability to scan and
modify people's memories she finds
memories about murakami when crossing
with murakami's friend nanami manages to
alter the assistant's memories of her
existence for the time being she wants
to enjoy herself in the outside world
more and then later manipulates
murakami's friends to lure him to her
nanami scans his memories and learns of
the observatory and the girls shocked
that nanami saw through him monakami
tries to convince her that there's hope
for her to live on her own disbelieving
nanami erases his memories and leaves
however our boy appears unaffected due
to his photographic memory and alerts
the girls they make the decision to end
the conflict peacefully with her after
staying at a hotel nanami tries to
socialize with people but doesn't know
how to make friends murakami neko and
kodori all wearing sunglasses find her
at the park and try wants to be her
friend neko takes off her glasses to
persuade naomi but she alters neko's
memory to attack murakami and kotori
when she finds neko remarking her as a
friend in her memories she realizes her
wrongdoing and undos her magic and
finally decides to go with them they
then take nanami to the observatory
where they meet murakami's uncle and
they ask him to find a way to remove the
beacon but before murakami's uncle can
do anything the beacon activates and
nanami melts to death as she melts she
erases the girls memories of her so that
they wouldn't have to suffer from her
death except murakami and his uncle
murakami laments over the death when
nanami suddenly appears beside him
saying that she inserted her
consciousness within his mind as she
knows secrets about the lab sometime
later while studying for test finals the
club members think about whether they
should continue going to school or not
since they only have three weeks worth
of pills left murakami reminds them how
they wanted to live as high school
students and motivates them to take a
trip to the beach elsewhere gizato takes
the initiative to release valkyria an
s-rank which to locate number of 1.107
he has a team of a-rank witches to
monitor her but she kills them all a
police squad confronts valkyria to
question her this provokes her to
unleash her anti-matter magic which
destroys the mountain they're on as this
occurs one of the witches hansuna
recovers from her wounds thanks to her
regeneration ability and sneaks away
from the police looking at what happened
the girls tell murakami that valkyria is
an ultimate hybrid with eight different
types of magic knowing that a fight with
valkyria is out of their league they
think of a strategy to avoid her hanzona
who overheard valkyria has detected
witches at an observatory and she goes
out searching for them she finds the
club members faking their deaths to
protect themselves hatsuna is then
welcomed to the astronomy club and goes
to wash at the hot springs while there
the girls tell her how reliable murakami
is later testing if he really is
trustworthy she pretends to be
helplessly stuck on a radio tower and
cause murakami to get her she
deliberately slips off and murakami
grabs her refusing to let go despite her
regeneration power murakami swings her
back onto the tower but sends him
falling to the ground luckily kodori
saves him at which point this relieves
hatsuna touched by monogamy's actions
hatsuna bluntly confesses and kisses him
in front of the others this causes neko
to blast down the tower in jealousy
later murakami's uncle calls him with
the theory that the witch's melting
condition is based on a digestive enzyme
protease using a thesis that he learned
from a man in college who turns out to
be chisato it's possible to shorten the
time of producing the pill however it
will still take a month meanwhile
gisanto appears before valkyria and
requests said to take him to where
number 1107 is
murakami returns with the bitter sweet
news with only 30 pills left there's a
possibility for one of the witches to
survive kotori carries some juices then
accidentally spills them on neco
exposing her chest monarch army
rediscovers the birthmark on her breast
and that she actually is guroneko crying
in tears of joy murakami reconciles with
nako and declares that he will help fill
in her empty memories they spot a
helicopter coming their way and before
they can escape valkyria appears who to
murakami looks identical to neko albeit
with white hair valkyrie and chisato
arrive at the observatory where they
demand to hand over number 1107 who is
in fact kodori murakami distracts them
for hatsuna to jump valkyria from behind
but they can't figure out which button
to push as a harness is complex valkyria
slices hatsuna in half wanting an
explanation of why they had to be killed
gisanta states the b rank witches are
irrelevant he orders valkyria to kill
neco but murakami pushes her away and
takes the hit losing consciousness
nanami appears in front of murakami
divulging the fact that neco used to be
an s rank which stronger than valkyria
and that the only way to regain her
powers is to press the top button of a
harness however the method is highly
risky after that murakami dies with the
girls distressed and defenseless
valkyrie is about to finish them off but
then the mysterious group of black
clothed individuals arrive who
neutralized valkyrie's magic following
the device's signal that murakami turned
on earlier nonetheless gizato escapes
with valkyria's teleportation taking
corduri along with them han tsuna
recuperates herself and uses her ability
to heal murakami with the help of neko
and kazumi performing cpr they revive
murakami hatsuna melts in the process
the black clothed individuals introduced
themselves as a group resisting the lab
stating the witches still must die
because of the creatures inside them the
witch's true form that will eventually
hatch and devour their bodies giving
birth to monsters moreover corduri has
an entity entitled the grain that can
destroy all humanity the men in black
tried to capture cordori once but failed
although it was during this incident
that they lost their comrade akane and
led to the other witches being able to
escape rodori awakens before gisanto
calling her rena rena wished his aunto's
younger sister who believed in the only
life meaningful to him until she died of
an unknown sickness he tells cortori how
aliens were believed to be the creation
of humans on earth his efforts to revive
reyna's soul within kodori's body ended
in vain meanwhile kazumi hacks into the
lab's database to find chisato's
location and demands the men in black
take them along godori asks shizanto
what he feels for valkyria though he
answers that she's merely someone
important to his plan suddenly kotori's
highness gets activated and shoots a
light into the earth's atmosphere that
begins covering the planet the light
covers the earth with the men in black
just staying helpless so murakami neko
and kazumi go to rescue godori on their
own neko and kazumi knock murakami out
not wanting him to risk his life any
longer gizato remarks that the
higher-ups aim to use the light to reset
the earth to a whole new era gottori
responds to gizato how she wants others
to smile regardless of her life so she
ejects her own harness therefore
cancelling the light phenomenon balkeria
slices kazumi in half but spares neko as
she's her little sister as nanami guides
murakami he finds gordori's body melting
listening to her final words she asks
murakami to tell her big brother not to
harm anyone and that she was happy till
the very end shizanto commands to have
naiko ejected when murakami hits him
aside shouting out kodori's words at him
malkiria uses gravity manipulation on
murakami and neco then ghana quickly
intervenes who's now able to move when
having her top button pressed for the
cost of her forecast magic neko then
presses her top button as well her full
power is now awakened and her memories
as kuroneko munakami's childhood friend
are restored makeup forms a barrier to
counter valkyria the man in black
neutralizes valkyrie's magic and then
fire at her with their guns but gizanto
shields her from the bullets which is
utter dead she now believes the world is
meaningless and attempts to unleash her
antimatter magic neko kisses muakami
before using a micro black hole on her
sister which swallows her up for good
murakami grabs neco from falling off a
collapsing cliff neko seems to have over
exerted herself and unfortunately loses
all her memories again murakami's uncle
later calls that they've miraculously
obtained the formula needed to reproduce
the pills for the witches in the credits
they returned to school with murakami's
uncle and the men in black continuing
their research on aliens in the lab the
astronomy club begins a fresh start on
an astronomical observation with kazumi
restored thanks to hatsuna and the show
ends with murakami showing nako the
summer triangle in the sky through the
telescope
that's all folks don't forget to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
notification bell see you next time